my first thought when i woke up this
morning probably like a non-verbal anger
despite her stunning smile disney star
dove cameron has been through
way more than her fair share of
tragedies she's been refreshingly open
about her mental health issues but it's
no wonder she describes her childhood
as dark and fans have noticed that even
her music has a certain edge to it
it's easy to envy dove cameron she's
talented wealthy and gorgeous
seriously how does she get her skin so
flawless but even though she makes it
look effortless the star has fought hard
to be where she is today
and she's the first to admit she had the
craziest childhood imaginable and just
in case you think she's exaggerating
let us fill you in on a few details when
dove cameron was eight years old
she started performing in community
theater but that same year she also
experienced a terrible tragedy
her best friend's father took the lives
of both of his daughters before claiming
his own
it was a devastating tragedy for dove
and when she was 15 she also lost her
father
after his long battle with depression
according to dove
she has very few physical mementos of
her time with her dad
and feels as though her life has now
been split into two parts before she
lost her father and afterwards
as a way to pay tribute to that chapter
of her life she legally changed her name
from chloe celeste hosterman to
dove cameron since his nickname for her
was dove
in an interview with entertainment
weekly dove revealed that it was only
after her father's passing that she
learned he had been closeted
finding this out was a huge surprise but
also explained a lot about his past
behavior
including his bursts of anger dove has
called him the most fascinating human
being
and she said she'd love to create a
movie about his life someday
unfortunately school was far from a
refuge for dove who is subjected to
relentless bullying from her peers
although her mother told her that her
tormentors were likely in pain
themselves
dove ended up leaving school revealing
that she felt incredibly lonely and
depressed
she's always felt misunderstood and told
her mother that she doubted she'd ever
be in a relationship
because i never thought that anybody
would quite understand me
you might find it strange that dove is
so open about her painful past
but this star claims it's just part of
her healing process
she finds it too difficult to put on a
happy face when she's going down
and feels as though hiding the darker
aspects of her life is doing herself a
disservice
the reality is she's not happy all the
time and she doesn't have the energy to
pretend she is
according to dove she was depressed long
before she was famous
and this made it hard to adjust to being
in the spotlight the star has described
herself as fragile
and says the ups and downs of the
audition process really took a toll on
her
from the get-go dove had a squeaky clean
image but says
this is because she was too afraid to
share her true self with her growing fan
base
she also felt pressure to be a good girl
and behave a certain way or risk
disappointing people
now she's called celebrity culture
incredibly toxic
but there was a time when she wanted
desperately to fit in
it was hard for dove to get used to
being in the spotlight and she admits
that the first time she was approached
for her autograph in public she totally
panicked
being recognized outside of work made
her realize
that she was now totally exposed and
there was no going back
you're just like your whole life you're
just like normal normal dove started out
performing in plays like les mis and the
secret garden but her big break
was when she began working for disney
she filmed a pilot for a show called
bits and pieces which later became the
disney channel hit
liv and maddie in which she played the
titular twins
her next big acting gig was also disney
related as she took on the role of mal
in the descendants franchise
dove became close to her co-stars and
considered them a sort of family
sadly one morning in 2019 she woke up to
her phone ringing off the hook and
learns that her close friend
and fellow descendants cast member
cameron boyce had passed away
due to epilepsy working with cameron
you know it's it's like working with um
your family
dove said she and cameron were good
friends almost immediately and it was
impossible not to be charmed by his
charismatic bright and brilliant
personality
she loved him like a brother and she
said he taught her how to be patient and
resilient
like everybody's talented in the films
but like cameron
cameron's really next level at first
dove tried not to talk about the tragedy
because grieving her loss felt too
private
but later she realized that being open
about her feelings and connecting with
others
could help with the healing process she
even got a tattoo in his memory
and teamed up with the cameron boyce
foundation on what would have been his
21st birthday
dove helps launch a new t-shirt for the
foundation which shows the same design
she has inked on her arm proceeds from
these limited edition shirts will
support the foundation's efforts to end
violence and cure epilepsy
and a portion of the cells will also be
donated to the actor's fund covet relief
cameron would also spend his birthday
doing something charitable to help
others
and now dove is keeping up his good work
in his memory
obviously working with the disney
channel was a huge boost to dove's
career
but working for the house of mouse also
came with its own set of challenges
as if being associated with this
family-friendly company wasn't enough
dove also started dating her liv and
maddie co-star ryan mccarten
the double dose of having her first
relationship play out in public and
feeling pressure to conform to disney's
standards
was devastating she felt like she had to
be perfect 24 7
and there was no room for her true
feelings or to deal with her mental
health issues
even though we now know more about what
really happened with ryan
deb admits that she capped her lowest
lows to herself
even though fans loved her active social
media presence
doug confessed she wasn't sharing much
about her true self
at first she tried to remain quiet about
the reasons behind their breakup
saying only that there was still love
between them and thanking fans for their
support
but ryan immediately threw dove under
the bus by blaming her for the split
he vented to the allegedly podcast that
the situation was really hard and that
he still loved her very much
and then he doubled up his accusations
not only did he blame dove for ending
their engagement but he accused her of
cheating on him first
despite this dove impressively managed
to stay positive
saying only that she felt better
stronger and more capable than she had
in years
in light of her breakup with ryan she
didn't even dignify his accusations with
a direct response
instead declaring that she was ready to
start showing up for life again
you know we all have exes ending her
relationship with ryan was one thing
but another major change in dove's life
was leaving disney
a lot of fans wondered if there was any
resentment when she pulled away from the
company that made her a star
but according to dove she's just
exploring different projects
she's compared leaving disney to moving
out of your parents house to go to
college
but admits it wasn't easy for so long
being a disney star had been a huge part
of her identity
and it caused her to question who she is
as a person but now that i'm not in it
who am i she didn't realize how much her
environment was connected to the
public's perception of her
but she hopes fans can look forward to
discovering dove the musical artist
but if you love seeing this star in
action don't worry although she's
throwing herself into her musical career
she doesn't see herself giving up acting
in fact she says being on stage or in
front of cameras actually helps her feel
confident
and motivates her to pull herself
together when she's struggling
she's hoping that her songs will help
show people that she's not just a disney
kid and admits her music might be a bit
darker than fans will expect
based on her descendants movies when
dove was growing up and feeling lonely
listening to music helped her cope with
her depression and anxiety
music helped me as a medium to kind of
understand myself and where i was in my
life so it's understandable that her
songs aren't always cheerful
she calls herself a dark person who just
happened to have a career path that was
very shiny
a lot of people think her song bloodshot
is a breakup anthem but that's not the
case
it was much more of a song about loss
which is a common theme
in my life and the lives around me she
admits to being inspired by some
experiences of her co-writer
carly page waldrip but says she
purposely kept the lyrics more
open-ended instead of making it about
the end of a relationship
in fact dove says she doesn't like
breakup songs and growing up she felt
like the only person who never connected
with taylor swift songs
not being a taylor swift fan actually
made dove feel like there must have been
something
wrong with her another song inspired by
her own experiences
is remember me which she claims is about
the human experience and embracing
aspects of life which are admittedly
less than great
dove believes that the first step
towards being able to connect with other
people
is having the ability to connect with
yourself i just would love to encourage
people to
delve into like the messier sides of
themselves music allows dove to express
herself
and it also helps manage her mental
health because not only does she have
anxiety
she has unbelievable anxiety although
being famous has had its downsides
dove's struggles predate her time in the
spotlight i think i was depressed long
before i was famous
i think i was anxious long before i ever
even moved to l.a
instead of being afraid of the spotlight
she tries to use her platform to lift
other people up
she hopes being open about her own
issues will let others know that they're
not alone
dove admits to falling into the trap of
trying to appear perfect on social media
but if she could let everyone know one
thing it would be that there is nobody
in the world that ever has it all
together
um no matter how much they look like
they do despite all the craziness of
well the year 2020 dove's doing her best
to keep it together
two days ago i had like a massive
breakdown and i was like humans aren't
meant to be cooped up
she encouraged her fans to practice
self-care even if it's more therapy
sessions than splurging on face masks
dove also has a lot of support from her
partner thomas doherty and it seems like
things between them are going pretty
well
but is she the one like do you talk
about that
yeah yeah yeah she and thomas even
attended protests together
and you know what they say the couple
who protest together
stays together okay so they don't really
say that but maybe they should
we love that dove is taking charge of
herself and her career
and her happiness she's also letting her
fans in on even the less than perfect
moments of her life what do you think
about dove's career progression from
disney star to musician
do you appreciate her openness about her
struggles or do you think she's guilty
of over-sharing
let us know what you think about dove in
the comment section below and don't
forget to click on the subscribe button
for more new videos from us here at the
things
thanks for watching